alexia a été diagnostiquée à l'âge de 74
ans d'un cancer du sein elle en informe
seulement ses proches et commencent les
traitements et examens en sortant de sa
consultation à l'hôpital elle tombe sur
le stand octobre rose et témoigne de son
histoire
je sensibilise tous les genres si c'est
nécessaire de les sensibiliser donc
qu'on fasse des choses telles que je
vois aujourd'hui plus souvent puisque
les femmes ne reçoivent plus à partir de
74 ans les invitations pour faire la
mammographie et celles qui ne sont pas
conscientes comme moi je l'étais peuvent
se retrouver avec quelque chose de plus
en 2010 8 environ 58 1400 cancer du sein
ont été diagnostiqués
douze mille personnes sont décédées à la
suite de ce cancer
le centre de coordination des dépistages
des cancers incitent les femmes de plus
de 50 ans a effectué leur mammographie
l'intérêt du stand c'est de pouvoir
expliquer aux femmes en croit le
dépistage est important faut savoir
aujourd'hui que le cancer du sang
c'est le premier cancer qui touche les
femmes aujourd'hui en france et c'est la
première cause de mortalité par cancer
donc il à la fois le plus récurrent est
le plus mortel pour les femmes
l'intérêt du dépistage et d'éviter
d'avoir un cancer qui se dégrade plus la
mammographie est effectué tôt plus les
chances de traiter un cancer rapidement
sont bonnes pour éviter des traitements
lourds mammographie est un examen qui
est
on dit douloureux il n'est pas
douloureux il les agréables l'appareil
comprime le saint automatiquement et
s'arrête automatiquement avant que ce
soit douloureux et donc
fait des incidences qu'on appelle ça de
face de profil de manière à localiser la
tumeur dans le singe un examen
désagréable mais qui peut sauver des
vies tout le mois d'octobre des actions
seront menées à travers les départements
pour sensibiliser au dépistage du cancer
du sein